der ukraine krieg und der nato gipfel
haben natürlich auch auswirkungen auf
die bundeswehr nato-generalsekretär jens
stoltenberg hat ja bereits angekündigt
man wolle die schnelle eingreiftruppe
der nato von bisher rund 40.000 soldaten
auf weit mehr als 300.000 erhöhen dass
dabei deutschland auch einen erheblichen
beitrag leisten wird steht wohl außer
frage und darüber will ich mal sprechen
mit andré wüstner dem vorsitzenden des
deutschen bundeswehrverbands guten
morgen guten morgen vielleicht erstmal
zu dem was bisher schon alles im vorfeld
des gipfels von der nato bekannt
geworden ist also vergrößerung der
eingreiftruppe stärkung der ostflanke
grünes licht auch für die nord
erweiterung in schweden und finnland wie
bewerten sie all diese signale die jetzt
vom gipfel kommen ja was wir da erleben
ist jetzt tatsächlich ein
paradigmenwechsel ein zurück zur alten
raum verantwortung vergleichbar vor 1990
also einzelne bündnispartner die räume
zugewiesen bekommen an der ostflanke und
ein verstärkender einsatzbereitschaft
eigentlich auf dem weg in richtung
kalter krieg 2.0 und ich glaube alle
sind sie noch nicht diese dimension
bewusst was deutschland anbelangt sie
sagten es wir sind momentan in der
vorreiterrolle in europa was drucken
bestellung anbelangt und das ist eine
riesenherausforderung für die bundeswehr
aus einem zustand der kleinsten
bundeswehr aller zeiten jetzt diese
aufgabe bis 20 24 25 übernehmen zu
können da hat die
verteidigungsministerien einiges zu tun
hat sie dann den paradigmenwechsel
grundsätzlich für richtig er ist richtig
erfolgt natürlich dem was eigentlich
seit der annexion der krim zumindest in
den dokumenten beschrieben ist aber nie
real umgesetzt wurde jetzt ist es so
dass alle aufgewacht sind alle
verstanden haben was gerade passiert und
ja dieses alte strategische konzept das
ja schon mal gewirkt hat glaubhafte
abschreckung wehrhaftigkeit als
grundlage für einen dialog dahin geht
man jetzt und wir alle können nur hoffen
dass das funktioniert und wir mittel-
bis langfristig auch irgendwann wieder
in eine phase der abrüstung kommen dann
kommen wir zu den konkreten folgen für
die bundeswehr wir haben eine grafik
vorbereitet mit aktuellen zahlen können
uns mal anschauen insgesamt leisten
gerade 183 1427 soldatinnen und soldaten
ihren dienst bei der bundeswehr da von
3.720 im ausland für die nato response
force die schnelle eingreiftruppe hält
deutschland aktuell 14.200 kräfte bereit
ein teil von ihnen kann innerhalb von
zwei bis drei tagen weltweit für
einsätze verlegt werden was bedeutet
jetzt die geplante vergrößerung dieser
eingreiftruppe auftrat mehr als 300.000
soldaten unserer daten für die
bundeswehr also erstmal muss klar werden
unabhängig davon was die bundeswehr in
auslandseinsätzen wirklich gutes leistet
wir haben der refokussierung auf die
landes- und bündnisverteidigung das
bedeutet auch eine strukturelle
anpassung denn all das was wir jetzt
sozusagen wieder liefern können müssen
war in den letzten jahren politisch
nicht mehr gewünscht strukturelle
anpassung zweites mal das thema
kallstadt fähigkeit sich zu organisieren
wie man kämpft all das große
herausforderung die wir jetzt den
nächsten jahren angehen müssen sind ein
riesen managementaufgabe für die
verteidigungsminister nicht nur im
bereich pater material sie erinnern sich
sondervermögen etc sondern auch eine
personelle herausforderung all das
personal zu gewinnen dass man jetzt zur
verfügung stellen würde aber
verteidigungsministerium hat ja schon
angekündigt 15.000 soldaten können
bereitgestellt werden 35 flugzeuge und
20 schiffe ist das realistisch ich gehe
davon aus es wird noch mehr werden
müssen und jetzt kommt eben die
herausforderung dort wieder hinzukommen
denn aktuell sie kennen ja die aussage
dass inspekteur des heeres man stehe
mehr oder weniger blank da das ist auch
mehr oder weniger politisch bestätigt
auch wenn das ein aufschlag war ein
brutaler öffentlich aber jetzt geht es
darum nicht mehr zurück zu schauen
sondern tatsächlich zu gestalten und man
muss das können und deswegen eben ganz
klar die aufführung seitens des
berufsverbandes nicht mehr nur ein
konzept nur für das schaufenster sondern
jetzt tatsächlich liefern warum weil es
eben um unser aller sicherheit geht um
damit auch frieden und deswegen noch mal
glaubhafte abschreckung als grundlage
für dialog und die 100 milliarden die
jetzt geplanten sondervermögen reichen
die dafür die werden nicht ausreichen
deswegen hat ja auch der kanzler nicht
nur von den 100 milliarden gesprochen
sondern eigentlich auch von den zwei
prozent unabhängig wie man jetzt die
prozentangabe steht aber eins muss klar
sein wenn man das bis 20.30 erreichen
will was man vorhat dann sprechen wir
von einem volumen von über 200
milliarden aber da ist zugesagt ist auch
in richtung nato da wir glaubhaftigkeit
unter beweis stellen da nicht
sichergestellt ist dass nach einem
präsident biden die amerikaner sich noch
so in europa und unsere
sicherheitsarchitektur kümmern wie jetzt
müssen wir diesen weg gehen auch wenn
wir beide sicherlich der auffassung sind
dass wir dieses geld auch für andere
politikfelder dringend bräuchten und
wenn die werbe auftrag des bundes
verfügen beklagt dass mangelnder
teilweise auch an unterwäsche wird den
versuch was jetzt auch gesorgt ja da hat
die verteidigungsministerin und das
parlament schon die entsprechenden
entscheidung getroffen da ist man auf
dem weg bis 2025 aber muss eben noch mal
unterstreichen was wir jetzt zu sagen
ein mehr an marina ein mehr an sozusagen
die luftwaffe ein mehr an her etc das
muss man alles noch unterfüttern und das
wird ein sehr anstrengender weg für die
nächsten zwei drei jahre
messlatte ist 20 25 das was wir jetzt in
der nato ein melden an fähigkeiten auch
unter beweis zu stellen und wir können
alle nur hoffen dass das gelingt
vielleicht noch eine kurze frage
brauchen wir für all das eigentlich auch
die wiedereinführung der wehrpflicht
aktueller stand sage ich nein die
debatte um das thema dienstpflicht
soziales pflichtjahr wie es der
bundespräsident angeregt hat halte ich
für richtig aber eins ist auch klar
gelingt es jetzt nicht in dieser
legislaturperiode die bundeswehr so
attraktiv zu machen dass wir das
ausreichende personal gewinnen dann
werden wir sicherlich auch wieder über
die wehrpflicht sprechen müssen
vorsitzender des bundeswehrverbandes
danke fürs gespräch und es nur dann
geben so